heal with reaction house oversight
committee chairman James Comer is with
us sir how are you
I'm well let's talk about these trips
some 15 I think you've confirmed that
Hunter Biden flies with Daddy I know
Peter Schweitzer makes the case and
secret Empires uh that two weeks after
uh Hunter flew with his father uh to
Asia and stopped in China then the Bank
of China the one billion dollar deal
that became 1.5 billion dollar deal was
struck as far as we have been able to
find Hunter has no experience in that
just like he has no experience and
energy do you believe that Hunter was
enriching himself on these trips
vis-a-vis the the free travel of his
father
there's no question Hunter Biden was
enriching himself and his family while
riding on Air Force two at the expense
of the American taxpayer but what's more
concerning is what Joe Biden's role was
in all of this and again John this is an
investigation of Joe Biden and what
we're doing now is we're putting a
timeline together on all these Bank
transfers that we've identified all the
bank wires we're trying to now put a
timeline with Communications that Hunter
had with his father with his so-called
Associates and we're finding that now he
was on Air Force 2 a whole lot more than
anyone thought so Joe Biden's role in
this family influence peddling scheme
continues to grow on a daily basis I
mean he was front and center in this
they can claim plausible deniability all
they want but I am here to tell you Sean
Joe Biden was front and center he met
with every one of these people that he
claimed he never met with had never
spoke to and we're putting together the
timeline where Hunter Biden was
traveling to many of these countries on
Air Force 2 while Joe Biden was vice
president and now we know from emails
from Hunter's laptop that the the person
that was in charge of money Rosemont
Seneca Eric Sherwin uh Hunter was asking
which account should I pay Dad's home
repair bills on Hunter said he gives
half his income to Pops Hunter
complained bitterly about paying for
those home repairs then we got are you
going to bring in Tony bobolinski and
ask him about 10 for the big guy
yeah yeah I expect to see Tony
bobolinski in front of an oversight
Committee hearing very soon I think he
wants to tell his story and I know the
American people want to hear the story
so we're definitely going to hear from
Bob olinski very soon with respect to
Sherwin we've been trying to communicate
with with Sherwin but uh look uh
sherwin's going to have to answer for
all of these transactions and we're
where you reference Sean where Hunter
Biden was paying for things for Joe
Biden in these accounts these are the
accounts we're now asking for and these
are the accounts we're probably going to
head to court in the very near future to
try to obtain they have stonewalled your
investigation the entire time it took a
long time for you to get the suspicious
activity reports the 1023 report you had
to threaten contempt to Congress for
director Ray before he finally handed
him over uh now the National Archives is
claiming that Joe Biden who is using
aliases or pseudonyms Robert Peters
Robin Ware J.R B Ware and they're saying
that you need to get permission from Joe
Biden to get the pseudonym email
accounts that are critical to your
oversight investigation uh and you're
going to need Barack Obama's approval
that's never going to happen that sounds
to me like they're covering for Joe and
they're trying to run out the clock so
you can't finish your investigation what
what tools do you have at your disposal
to expedite this
well I think there's consensus in our
conference now that we're going to have
to go to impeachment inquiry obviously
that'll be speaker McCarthy's call but I
feel like we're there now Sean I feel
like that's imminent and I believe that
that will be a tool in our toolbox when
we go to court with our subpoena look
we've requested these documents the
house oversight committee has
legislative jurisdiction over the
National Archives they've stonewalled Us
in the Biden mishandling of classified
documents now they're you know we hope
they don't stonewallis in the pseudonym
request there's 5 400 emails
have you seen any of these 50s
have you seen any of those I've seen a
few yes I've seen one that had Hunter
Biden copied and that's the most
concerning thing that's where the
Democrats have uh Gone Stone Cold silent
in Washington in their defense of Joe
Biden there was an email that was to
assume them that uh that was Joe Biden
that had Hunter copied on it and it was
an email about Ukraine policy at the
same time that Devin Archer testified
that the owners of Burris but were
squeezing Hunter to call Washington for
help and that's when Dan Goldman and
Jamie are asking says oh well he could
have called anybody in Washington and
I'm sure they just talked about the
weather that's not true I want to make
sure my timeline's right you correct me
if I'm wrong October of 2015 it became
official after an interagency study it
officially became an Obama
administration policy to give the one
billion dollars in loan guarantees to
Ukraine because they've made enough
progress regarding corruption same year
2015 December 4th Hunter is in Dubai
with Barista Executives asking for
exactly what you mentioned D.C help they
call Joe Biden in D.C get him on the
phone five days later is in Ukraine
leveraging a billion dollars to get a
prosecutor fired son of a bee they fire
the guy in six hours and Hunter Biden as
a result continues to get paid for work
by his own admission he had no
qualifications being paid for is that
correct is that timeline right
that that that's 100 correct and that's
very concerning and think about this
that's what the first Trump impeachment
was about Donald Trump simply asking
zelinski what he knew about that that
was the quid pro quo the quid pro quo
was Joe Biden withholding American tax
dollars to Ukraine in exchange for them
firing the prosecutor who was
investigating his son Hunter for
corruption last question are you
investigating bribery and money
laundering as it relates to the
president of the United States
yes that's our investigation we know
that the president's son committed money
laundering we're investigating whether
or not Joe Biden committed money
laundering but we're pretty certain he's
committed uh some pretty serious
the entire Congress will be concerned
about and nine members of this family
got paid through these shell
corporations uh you you stated that fact
and we believe now you have evidence
that Joe Biden benefited financially
himself although that's not even what
the statute calls for correct
I think so yes wow
James Comer thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else